CBS News has obtained the full contents
of the whistleblower memo at the center
of the house impeachment inquiry and a
Fox News poll released yesterday shows
51% of registered voters believe
President Trump should be impeached and
removed from office that's an increase
of 9% in the past three months
Ouiser jiang is at the white house we
show what more do we know about the
whistleblower well Anthony right now we
are talking about this memo because
President Trump continues to call it a
scam pointing to the whistleblower being
a registered Democrat CBS News has
learned that the person was a has a
prior working relationship with a
current Democratic presidential
contender but lawyers say their client
has never worked for or advised a
political party or a campaign and say
the real issue here is the president's
conduct and not the whistleblowers
resume I had a perfect phone call with
the president of Ukraine the
whistleblowers two-page memo
memorializes how a White House official
who was listening in described president
Trump's phone call as crazy frightening
and completely lacking in substance
related to national security the
official was visibly shaken the
president's personal lawyer Rudy
Giuliani tells CBS News the memo
discredits the whistleblowers formal
complaint this poor little [ __ ] was all
worried nobody was threatening anyone
but in the officials view mr. Trump had
clearly committed a criminal act he
should be impeached on Wednesday former
Vice President Joe Biden joined his
fellow 20/20 presidential candidates and
called for president Trump's impeachment
for the first time he shooting holes in
the Constitution and we can not let him
get away with it Biden also told CBS
Boston Station WBZ that he did nothing
wrong as vice president while his son
hunter served on the board of the
Ukrainian energy company I don't discuss
things with my son or my family because
I don't want to have any knowledge of
any I don't want to be accused of well
you talk with your son you talk with
your whomever Biden's camp says he
changed his mind on impeachment in part
because of the president's decision this
week to refuse to cooperate with
Congress the whole thing is a scam it's
a fix
with or without president Trump's
cooperation Democrats are charging
forward with their investigation CBS
News has learned that the three House
committees working on this have
requested that Fiona Hill the
president's former senior director for
Russia on the National Security Council
testify next week Tony all right we
should thank you very much